he has the only quarterback signed
through the 2024 season in the NFL right
now he's how he rose me to the
Philadelphia Eagles how are you how he
I'm doing great rich how you doing I'm
doing fine let's get right down to it
why did you go ahead and sign Wentz
earlier than a lot of folks expected
Howie
well we think that it was inevitable
that we were gonna sign Carson to a
contract extension it was something that
we wanted to do we know how talented he
is we know how he fits aren't off the
field for us so the sooner we were able
to commit to it the better chance we had
of keeping the rest of the team together
and being able to take some of those cap
charges in the years that he had left on
his rookie deal and hopefully as we move
forward here being able to surround him
with a bunch of good players and make
another run in a championship and in
terms of signing him when you did did
you take into account or factor that
other quarterbacks obviously one in your
division with dak in Dallas and the guy
who was drafted directly in front of him
in Los Angeles in golf that if you get
in right now that you might get a better
price for your player Howie
well the great part about doing deals
early is there's risk on both sides and
so those are usually the best
opportunities to find win-win situations
and we understood that when you're
talking about the kind of money that we
committed to this player that there's no
discount and it's it's full price and at
the same time we're excited about being
able to do that lock it in and figure
out going forward the best way to
surround him but certainly you look at
all the circumstances around and the
history of the league it's no secret
says that as you move forward and the
cab moves forward prices go up and then
we see the number what what what the
contract is and a lot of fans see that
and think that you are now gonna be a
bit hamstrung and as you pointed out to
surround Carson with guys and re-sign
guys that you've saw already surrounded
Carson with because of how much he costs
how would you respond to that Howie the
thing we have to do is we got to
continue to get more draft packs the
last couple of years based on some of
the trades that we made and
certainly wouldn't change those
circumstances to give us the best chance
to compete and win we traded some draft
picks and going forward we know we need
more draft picks we got to hit on those
draft picks at a higher percentage now
the draft it's a crapshoot you know as
you go through the draft even when
you're in the first round your
percentage rate it's not like you know
you're in the first round you got an 80%
hit rate especially hopefully you're
picking in the in the bottom third of
the round but the more opportunities you
get the more shots you get it at that
lottery the better chance you get so
that's on us that's on me to make sure
that we continue to get more picks and
with some of the free agent losses that
we had this year we already know that
next year and the draft will have more
picks and hopefully I can have the the
patients and I'll trade those picks
requires lose out in the past well I
guess that's what I'm doing right now
keeping you see this is a win win for
you and for me then Howie I know I like
the action that's that's part of the
reason why you do what you do but so the
interesting part about a draft pick
obviously is it's called the player is
cost-effective compared to what else
you're talking about but eventually
though if they you do hit on them you do
have to pay them so how does it work the
cap hit for Carson that makes this a win
for for you and the Philadelphia Eagles
in that regard Howie Roseman well if you
wait two more years or you sign a player
at the end of his deal you're not able
to prorate some of that charge over a
longer period of time but this has
really been our philosophy going back
since I've been in Philly is to try to
sign guys target guys identify guys you
know the difference between having guys
on your own team and signing guys and
phrase and see is you've lived with them
and so you know it's it's like it's like
before you get married you know you're
ready you ready to live with them you
already know their good and bad habits
and so you know what you're buying and
for us that that we should be able to
know our own team the best and so we're
going to continue to try to identify
those guys tomorrow Lee I mean that's
going to be really the crux
of how we do things here and if you go
and look back in 2016 the first thing we
did before we made the Carson trade
before we got into free agency is we
signed a bunch of our guys to extensions
and we want people here on and off the
field to know that if they do the right
thing they do a good job there's no
reason to leech how are you rose Mann
executive vice president the
Philadelphia Eagles here on the Rich
Eisen show your concern about Carson's
health is what how much did you factor
that into this contract Howie Carson
looks great you know we get the
opportunity to see him out here every
day obviously we have our doctors we
have a team of doctors on every player
not just Carson so we're fully confident
in Carson and we couldn't be more
excited to get this going I'd like to
say that I wish it was September but
after all the action in the last few
weeks maybe in a week I can say that
better maybe maybe get away for a week
and then I'll be really excited in all
in all seriousness when it all comes
down to it though the the the guys we
all know as talented as he is as special
as he is both on and off the field has
not been able to stay on the field to
finish the last couple of seasons is
that any concern level at all for you in
the front office Ali I think our actions
speak louder than our words here rich
and you know we wouldn't do this if we
had any doubt about what Carson's going
to do going forward and you know he does
a great job and taking care of his body
and like everything in life you know
your experiences are a great teacher
four things that you can do going
forward and I just you know you're the
perfect person to ask this he's an
executive vice president of the Eagles
Howie Roseman here on the Rich Eisen
show I don't know if you saw I guess a
colleague of yours in the NBA and Bob
Meyers last night the general manager of
the Golden State Warriors getting very
emotional at the microphone after Kevin
Durant injured himself again in a game
and a lot of people are wondering some
why he was playing can you walk me
through the process of a front office
and putting a player on the field that's
significant clearly for the franchise
Carson would be a perfect example who is
hurt banged up and the concept of
putting him
into the fray in that regard now first
first you know Baba is a friend and
someone yeah obviously you're in that
situation we were in that situation we
were in that situation a couple years
ago we were down in LA and Carson got
hurt and you know I think there was one
thing it does is it gives your your
leadership your team the character of
your team an opportunity to do something
special and really kind of do it in that
and that person's name really and they
have a great opportunity and they've
such a great character and leadership on
that team from the front office coaching
staff on down that I know they'll
rebound and wish them the best of luck
as they go forward but you know I think
a lot of times people don't understand
this process which I get and and really
it's controlled by doctors and and your
medical staff and not only that but you
have so many outside consultants when
you're talking about superstar players
and really all your players that
nobody's just getting one opinion on
these injuries nobody's just taken for
example the team's opinion or the
players doctor's opinion you're getting
all those opinions together and it's a
collaboration of information and you're
not doing anything especially when you
talk about you know player who's about
to free agency and I can't speak to
individually that situation but they're
they're doing everything in a way that
is totally transparent for the player
for the team and only making that
decision like I saw his interview this
morning when it's nobody's fault things
happen you know it's the nature of the
game and so I think that sometimes
there's this perspective that you know
the team is making the call only but you
have so many people involved in these
decisions on all sides and all of these
things are aboveboard
so what did you think of when you saw
them get emotional you know I I just
took me back to where we were in in LA
that time but also really throughout the
course of my time here when you have
players that you care about and they're
like your kids or like fingers on your
hands I mean it's hard to see guys you
care about suffering
and not being able to perform and you
know I know I think about I was thinking
about the fact that when we were in
Minnesota preparing for the Super Bowl
and we had this group of guys and it was
Carson and with Jason Peters and it was
Chris Maragos and it was Darren Sproles
and it was Jordan Hicks and those those
guys those guys just working out and
while the team was preparing to play in
the Super Bowl and just feeling for them
you know and knowing that they work all
these hours they do all this stuff they
train just to have this opportunity it's
hard it's hard you know this is why you
do all that the Eagles executive VP
Howie Roseman here in the Rich Eisen
show a couple more minutes left with him
so let's just return if you don't mind
to the the concept of signing a
quarterback for as much money as you did
this is the system now right Howie I
mean like you draft somebody get a
couple of years of a window in their
first contract to try and win with them
you did in fact although it was as you
point out Nick Foles who was the one who
went through that legendary run in the
playoffs but this seems to be the the
system right now in the NFL that at some
point you're gonna have to pay somebody
who in the case of Carson for injury has
never won a playoff game ever even
played in a playoff game and you're
gonna have to do that is that a good
system yeah I think that that's the the
way that we all grew up knowing this was
what you do this is the ideal system is
you get a player that you think's a
superstar player at the most important
position in sports and you build around
them and and do you understand that that
guy gives you a chance to win and we
talk about how much success we had in
the playoffs with Nick but we wouldn't
have been there if it wasn't for Carson
and the success he had and what he did
for our football team and this guy's 26
years old he supremely talented he's got
an amazing work ethic and he makes
everyone around him better and that's
what you look for and you get these
opportunities and you're hopeful that
this is someone that you could build
around for a long time you know really
goes back in 2016 when we made this
trade and gave up all those picks for
for Carson I thought the thing that was
really the most powerful for us
was that you think about the 2004 draft
and the Giants training for Eli and the
Philip Rivers and Ben and how long those
guys play to be able to recruit the
picks but also giving their team a
chance to being attention every year
when you have that guy and so that
that's the exciting part about that and
that puts it back on us and our
responsibility to make sure we continue
to get good players in here and build a
team that also has some depth and that's
what we're going to continue to try to
do and you know I think by doing it
early gives us a better chance even if
it's just to keep one or two more
players than we would have this we did
this year or two from them so how how
far in advance is someone in your
position plan for that too for instance
the Cardinals just drafted Kyle Emery
first overall do they sit down right now
and say three four years from now it all
works out we've got to have this much
money available I mean how does it work
in terms of planning purposes with this
estate I enjoyed the moment for a little
bit don't you read anyone till after
they played three years on their rookie
deal so I I'd like to think looking back
at it now from my perspective them maybe
we enjoyed the moment of building around
it and giving him an opportunity to
develop into the player he was you know
they took a huge jump he had a really
good rookie year but took a huge jump
from year one to year two and then you
get into a position where you see him
have some adversity and how he overcomes
adversity and his work ethic and again
it's just the more you know about
someone the more experiences you have
with someone more confident you are and
in committing to them and so I think for
us that that's how when and when you
have a guy who's got all these traits
and you see how hard it is to find that
guy and when you find that guy it gives
you a chance to compete every year you
don't want to lose that so you're
telling me to live in the moment how is
that your way of telling me to live in
the moment right now
I like the moment rich I do you know I
like the moment there could be part of
you though that still got to think about
the future right but at the same time
here you got to enjoy you guys enjoy the
run a little bit I know
unfortunately some teams don't let you
do that and
yes in the last couple minutes I have
with you here what are your thoughts on
a couple of your colleagues losing their
gigs in between the draft and and the
beginning of the the summer how in one
of them in New York led to you losing
Joe Douglas in your front office what is
happening in our business right now like
The Godfather movies this is like we've
chosen you're going Hyman Roth on me you
know where my head is Moses and that's
it it's a tough business it's a very
bottom line business and sometimes even
the bottom line doesn't always work out
and you hate to see good people you'll
be out of a job and it's just man you
know it just it you understand when you
get into this that you got to win and
you got to surround yourself with with
good people on and off the field and all
of us are just a product of the people
that are we have around us and you know
you talk about Joe and what great guy
he's been for all of us and what a great
opportunity he has in New York but we'll
miss him and it stinks it stinks to lose
good people it stinks it was good
players and I guess that's the price of
having some success so I'm hoping that
maybe we continue to lose good people
and good players because that will
probably mean we're still doing well
Howie thanks to the call a jury of
whatever down time is coming your way
and we'll chat down the line training
camp and beyond I really appreciate it
look forward to it thanks rather that's
how heroes many Eagles executive VP here
on the Rich Eisen show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app